[Música]
estas imágenes de contaminación por
petróleo fueron grabadas en gabón el
séptimo productor de petróleo del
continente africano estamos en la región
de timbó ue en move a la fuga procede de
un yacimiento petrolífero explotado por
la empresa franco británica perenco
voy a ver el arco
y este derrame no es un caso aislado
perenco explota viejos pozos comprados a
gigantes del petróleo a bajo costo la
empresa se convirtió en el primer
operador nacional en un país que depende
del oro negro
el sector petrolero representa el 60 por
ciento de los ingresos presupuestarios
de gabón
pero desde hace varios años los
activistas acusan a la empresa de
contaminación reiterada y lo documentan
con vídeos de
soluciones
y tratan de mostrar su impacto sobre el
medioambiente y los habitantes
como podemos explicar esta reiterada
contaminación quien es el responsable lo
investigamos con nuestros observadores
me llamo bernal cristian tula y llevo
varios años documentando la
contaminación por petróleo en la región
de let in way en la región de lo que
marketing en gabón
[Música]
en mayo nos alimentaron de una
contaminación
que se estaba produciendo en la zona de
móvil allá hay una tubería que se rompió
en todo eso el crudo se derramó en la
naturaleza en un radio de más de 400 a
500 metros
gracias a los drones puedes sobrevolar y
ver el emplazamiento de moma donde se
produjo la fuga de petróleo
bernard cristian regulada y otros
activistas elaboraron una lista de 10
emplazamientos contaminantes desde
octubre de 2019 todos están ubicados
junto a los yacimientos petrolíferos de
la empresa perenco esta empresa familiar
está presidida por françois perrodo una
de las 20 personas más ricas de francia
en gabón de timbúes es una de las
principales regiones productoras de
petróleo pero sus bosques y lagunas son
también una fuente de sustento para los
habitantes cerca del emplazamiento
petrolífero de batanga lidia y revela se
ha visto afectada por las consecuencias
de la contaminación repetida
[Música]
soy consumidora de pescado antes era
pescadora tuve que dejar de hacerlo
porque la pesca ya no es rentable
no pasamos seis meses sin contaminación
y tuvimos que destruir las mallas
afectadas por el crudo
los pescadores le enviaron al equipo de
los observadores fotos en las que se ven
manchas de crudo en el agua redes
cubiertas de petróleo y peces muertos
que según ellos se deben a la
contaminación
esta es el agua que la gente toma cuando
va a las zonas de pesca de camp
permanente no todo el mundo puede pagar
una bolsa de agua
algunos pescadores lograron ser
indemnizados por perenco pero para
muchos esto no es suficiente teniendo en
cuenta los daños sufridos en su región y
resulta que perenco como empresa no
respeta las normas medioambientales
básicas
a pesar de su preocupación ningún
estudio ha mostrado las consecuencias de
estos derrames en el medio ambiente y en
la salud de los habitantes
tengo hijos tengo nietos
que les vamos a dejar de herencia mental
al principio de 2021 el ministerio
gabonés del medio ambiente visitó la
región de tiempo web
señaló varios incidentes que podrían
haber causado la contaminación atribuida
a perenco el ministerio solicitó una
auditoría de las infraestructuras de la
empresa
[Música]
algunas de las infraestructuras
utilizadas por perenco en gabón fueron
construidas hace más de 60 años por el
grupo total el petróleo estaba en pleno
boom en aquella época
[Música]
en la actualidad la producción disminuye
en 1997 de gabón producía 18 millones de
toneladas de petróleo en 2021 esta cifra
se redujo a 10 millones ya que los
yacimientos petrolíferos tienen una vida
útil
después de varios años la extracción de
petróleo se hace cada vez más difícil y
menos rentable las gigantes del petróleo
como total se han ido vendiendo
paulatinamente sus activos que están al
final de su vida útil para invertir en
nuevos proyectos más prometedores
al comprar los activos de total en 2017
perenco se convirtió en el mayor
productor nacional de gabón
sin embargo según los activistas estas
infraestructuras deterioradas están mal
mantenidas y son fuente de contaminación
un trabajador de mantenimiento que
trabajó en las instalaciones de perenco
accedió a testificar
por miedo a las represalias testificó de
forma anónima y pidió que su voz fuera
modificada
las tuberías se dejan allá funcionan
durante años años años no se revisan las
tuberías están viejas muy viejas solo se
cambian cuando hay daños si no hay daños
mientras nuestro petróleo siga fluyendo
lo aprovechamos es una cuestión de
arreglos remiendan las cosas van a un
lugar recuperan cosas vuelven a armarlo
según nuestros observadores en la
primavera de 2022 la vejez de las
estructuras fue la causa de un gran
accidente
el 28 de abril fueron alertados de un
incidente de contaminación en cabo lópez
en port-gentil la capital económica de
gabón que es la principal terminal
petrolera del país desde noviembre de
2000 21 es operada por perenco
fui al lugar el día del desastre
a través de las imágenes proporcionadas
por mi dron y descubrí una vasta
extensión de crudo
el derrame se produjo por una fuga en
uno de los tanques de almacenamiento de
petróleo
aquí se ve un camión cisterna en medio
sumergido
unas horas después del incidente perenco
y el ministerio de petróleo gabonés
emitieron comunicados de prensa
ambos con la misma frase
todo el petróleo estaba contenido en los
depósitos de retención y no se observó
contaminación marina
lamentamos que las autoridades gabonesas
hayan repetido casi al pie de la letra
el comunicado de perenco
luego lamentamos esta falta de
transparencia a la comunicación
estudiantes esperado
sin embargo un vídeo grabado por un
empleado muestra que el petróleo se
derramó más allá de los tanques de
contención
las imágenes de satélite obtenidas por
france 24 tras la fuga muestran la
terminal de cabo lópez
los depósitos donde se almacena el
petróleo y los tanques de contención
como indican los comunicados de prensa
oficiales parte del petróleo se derramó
en los tanques de contención pero parte
del petróleo también se derramó fuera de
éstos
en este vídeo se puede incluso escuchar
una conversación por walkie talkies
sí
según las palabras de este empleado
efectivamente se había derramado
petróleo en la costa el accidente de
cabo lópez paralizó parte de las
exportaciones de petróleo durante un mes
perenco se negó a darnos una entrevista
el departamento de comunicación sólo nos
envió este comunicado este desafortunado
incidente aceleró la renovación prevista
de la terminal aprovecharemos esta
oportunidad para modernizarla
el director general de perenco gabón
anunció que se abriría una investigación
pero cuatro meses después del incidente
la empresa aún no se ha pronunciado
sobre el progreso de la investigación y
el calendario de las obras
tengo también es acusada de
contaminación en otros países dos
asociaciones francesas les amiga de la
teja y se van
la han demandado por derrames en la
república democrática del congo pero es
acaso perenco una excepción en la
industria petrolera philip calva o es
antropólogo especializado en industrias
extractivas
creo que la gran diferencia con empresas
como shell chevron o total es que suelen
estar más receptivas a los accionistas y
a la vez están más expuestos a la
opinión pública estas grandes compañías
se han dado cuenta de que es mejor no
estar asociadas a estos pozos que están
al final de su vida útil
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta los
efectos a largo plazo de la
contaminación que provocan
mientras que empresas como perenco en
que no es la única dentro de las
industrias extractivas
tienden a operar de formas más discretas
es bajo el radar como estas empresas no
suelen estar obligadas a pagar las
operaciones de limpieza dental tienden a
evitar cualquier forma de
responsabilidad ante las poblaciones
locales el trabajador de mantenimiento
que trabajaba para perenco denuncia la
negligencia del grupo en materia de
descontaminación por ejemplo trabajé en
la limpieza solíamos utilizar barreras
absorbentes las barreras permiten
detener la progresión de los aceites
intentamos circunscribir con barreras
para que los aceites no sigan su curso
ahora donde hay barro los aceites se van
al fondo y se mezclan con el barro van
directamente a las raíces cuando se
impide que el petróleo avance todo está
bien pero las aguas ya están
contaminadas y todas las especies que
viven en el agua están contaminadas en
el problema según los expertos en
geoquímica la limpieza efectiva requiere
que se bombea el petróleo y que se
retire la tierra contaminada uno
encuentra en lugares donde rellenan de
arena porque quieren terminar rápido el
tiempo es poco así que cuando uno va a
ver hay aceites que se quedan ahí y
salen después
están el amor
en gabón otras empresas petroleras son
acusadas de contaminación
es importante no ver a perenco como una
especie de némesis
en la industria petrolera es
fundamentalmente destructiva y creo que
las reglas del juego deben cambiar
james tonics trans en enero de 2021 una
organización de la sociedad civil
gabonesa aéreo lbg presentó una denuncia
contra perenco
el objetivo de este procedimiento no es
sólo obligar a perenco a regularizar sus
instalaciones
sino también poner en marcha análisis
para conocer el grado de contaminación
en la región de timbó
la empresa fue acusada por el tribunal
de port gentil al igual que perenco el
ministerio gabonés del medioambiente y
la dirección general de hidrocarburos no
respondieron a nuestras solicitudes